[Music]
love death and robots as Zima blue seems
to be the short that is most alien to
the overall feel of the collection it
possesses no violence gore or nudity and
yet it arguably is most akin to the
title love death and robots throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the inspiration for the episode its plot
and ending this is full spoilers ahead
so if you haven't had a chance to watch
the episode yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now as it's one of the
best from the series with that out the
way I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I explain it so you don't
have to zima blue is actually an
adaptation of the story of the same name
by Alastair Reynolds from his collection
of short tales called Zima blue and
other stories published in 2006 by
nightshade books the work contains 10
stories including this and beyond the
aquila rift which was also adapted for
the Netflix show the episode itself
follows a universally famous artist that
for the very first time is allowing the
presence of a journalist named Claire
Markham to gain insight into his life
throughout the episode we learn about
x'mas past work and his plans for the
future and through this we discover what
it means to be human and also not at the
same time initially we are told that
Zima began life as an artist in
portraiture before branching off into
the cosmos and painting vast murals that
one-by-one gain his signature style
azeema blue block color that slowly
begins to take over his artwork until
eventually it stretches far beyond it we
witness SEMA paint rings around planets
and this could potentially be an easter
egg for those who've seen the ending of
the fourth episode from love death and
robots titled suits as Zima begins to
divulge his history he informs Claire of
a practical seemingly unimportant robot
that a woman once used to clean her pool
she gained an affection for this robot
and over the years began upgrading it
giving it an almost human-like brain so
that it is able to create and advance
beyond its surroundings unfortunately
the woman dies and thus the machine is
shifted from owner to
receiving upgrades in the process we
learned that this robot is in fact SEMA
and that this autobiographical tale ties
into his final masterpiece which he's on
the verge of unveiling Zima has
collected the original pool that he used
to clean and rebuilt it as part of his
two-piece the titular Zima blue coloring
comes from the tiling of the pool and
it's important to the character as it's
the first thing that he ever laid eyes
upon after showcasing the final piece to
an audience
Zima jumps into the pool deconstructing
himself in the process and sharing all
of the upgrades that he's able to revert
back to the simplistic life that he once
had in my opinion the overwhelming urge
for Zima to return to this simplicity is
present throughout his work and its
representation of his world to return to
this state he's showcased by the fact
that the Zima blue coloring slowly took
over his pieces more and more till they
became the main fixation the closest
similarity to this in pop culture that I
can think of is the ending of Citizen
Kane in which the titular character
utters the word rosebud which is the
name that he had on his sled as a child
Kane's similar to Zima amassed a lot of
wealth traveled to countless places and
was regarded as almost godlike however
it did not stop this longing to return
to something that he lost long ago for
his entire life
Zima has been on a quest to find meaning
throughout not only the galaxy but also
his art however he realizes that the
most powerful and meaningful part of his
life was when he was not concerned about
the rest of the universe but rather the
simple task ahead of him this rebirth
that closes the episode out reminds us
that whilst we may strive for greatness
we will never truly attain enough to
feel complete and even in doing so there
will be dissatisfaction in going on an
ambitious journey we will have to
sacrifice and leave behind something
that is very dear to us and this is why
Zima returns to the pool because he
accepts that this is the happiest that
he ever was it's an amazing message that
really makes you appreciate what you
have around you and reminds us that
there is beauty to be found in
everything and that the greatest
pleasures come from the simplest things
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on Zima blue and if you agree with me or
if you took anything different from
make sure you leave them in the comments
below and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the ending of suits
from love death and robots which would
be linked after this video this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]